hi welcome back to our series on
embedding looker
previously we walked you through our SSO
embedding option
now let's dive into a common embedding
use case you can try out embedding a
dashboard with custom filters let's say
you have a looker dashboard embedded in
an iframe in your host applications
front end
the dashboard displays sensor results
and can filter its results based on the
state and county level the built-in
embedded filter UI is great but we want
the user to control the dashboards
filter through your host applications UI
let's build a custom filter UI in your
host application that well replace the
dashboards filter UI and seamlessly
control the embedded dashboards
filtering the implementation we'll use
react our look a components Library our
API SDK and our embed SDK
however you can achieve everything with
vanilla JavaScript 2.
if you'd like to try out the working
sample code check out our embed
reference Repository
links below
at a high level we will follow these
implementation steps we will
hide the dashboard's filter UI
build the host application's custom
filter UI
fetch the filter state from our local
API to initialize the custom filter UI
and lastly set up the custom filter UI
to message the embedded dashboard on
user input as always
a Quick Knowledge check before we
continue
you should be familiar with JavaScript
look at dashboard filters and the
previously mentioned implementation
dependencies
[Music]
all right
let's get started by hiding the
dashboard's filter UI
we need to hide it so your user can only
access the custom filters on your host
application UI
to do this we need to add a property to
the embed content URLs underscore theme
parameter
in this example we use the embed SDK to
create and manage the iframe
so we call the sdks with params method
with a JavaScript object that has an
underscore theme property we set the
theme property to the Json stream
representation of an object with a show
filters bar property set to false
this disables the dashboard's filter UI
when it is embedded in an iframe
keep in mind you must enable custom
themes in your local instance to do this
with the dashboards filter UI hidden
let's replace it with a custom filter UI
in your host application
in this example we use the react filter
component provided by our looker
components Library
it's linked in the description below the
filter component provides an input field
for the filter suggests to the user what
filter values are available and
communicates changes in the input field
to its parent component in this case
when you use the filter component you
need to pass in certain props
the available values or suggestions to
filter on the current values or
expression of your filter
the type configuration of the filter
like if it's a drop down menu
and other prompts
when your host application page loads we
need to initialize the filter
component's props with the state of the
dashboard filter to do this
we fetch the dashboards filter state
from the looker API and initialize the
filter component props with the fetched
state
for ease of use we will use our looker
API typescript SDK to call the API
endpoint
the SDK
is linked in the description below we
call the sdk's dashboard method with the
dashboard ID and use the fields argument
to specify that we only want the
dashboards filters properties returned
PK call returns all of the dashboards
filters and their properties like their
current values suggestions and more
we then initialize the filter component
props with the fetch properties
now with the filter component
initialized we need to set up the custom
filter to communicate user input to the
dashboard
the looker embed SDK returns a
convenient object that represents the
dashboard embedded in the iframe
we'll name that object dashboard
the dashboard object comes with the send
method for sending messages to the
iframe our filter component needs to
send two messages to the dashboard on
every filter value change
we first send a dashboard filters update
message with the new filter value
this tells the embedded dashboard to set
new values on its filters
and then
importantly we send a run message to the
dashboard to update its results
now when the user changes the filter
value in your custom filter component
the component tells the dashboard to
change its filter and update its results
and there you have it
we hit the dashboards filter UI replaced
it with a custom filter UI initialize it
with a dashboards filter State fetch
from the looker API and lastly set up
the filter component to update the
dashboard's filters and results
now your user can interact with your
host application UI to seamlessly filter
your embedded dashboard results
we hope this use case gives you a
glimpse of the flexibility of looker
embedding
we provide open source tools like the
looker embed SDK the looker component
library and the looker API SDK to help
you embed looker more easily
don't forget to try out the working
sample code in our looker embed
reference Repository
everything I mentioned
is linked below and with that
look out for more videos in this series
see you next time
[Music]